Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The dark eleventh hour draws on and sees us sold To every evil power we fought against of old. Rebellion, raping, hate, oppression, wrong and greed Are loose to rule our fate by England's act and deed. We asked no more than leave to reap where we had sown, through good and ill, to cleave to our own flag and throne. Now England's shot and steel beneath
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。黑暗的第十一个小时临近，我们被出卖给曾经对抗过的每一个邪恶势力。叛乱、强奸、仇恨、压迫、错误和贪婪，因英国的所作所为而肆意主宰我们的命运。我们别无所求，只求在播种之地收获，无论顺境逆境，只求忠于我们自己的旗帜和王座。现在，英国的枪炮之下
that flag must show how loyal hearts should kneel to England's oldest foe. We know the war prepared on every peaceful home. We know the hells declared, for such as serve not Rome. The terror, threats and dread in market, hearth and field. We know when all is said, we perish if we yield. Believe we dare not boast. Believe we do not fear. We stand to pay the cost in all that men hold dear. What answer from the north? One law, one land, one throne. If Englandling poem, Ulster, was written by Rudyard Kipling and published in the Morning Post on the 9th of April, 1912. And it's a call to arms, isn't it, by Kipling on behalf of what he sees as the guardians of the British flame, the people of Ulster, or as we would now say, well, what eventually becomes the state or statelet or province, whatever you'd like to call it, of Northern Ireland. So here we are, and a civil war is approaching. It is, Dominic. And I think that listeners will be able to tell from that that we are now a long way from the GPO in Dublin, where we were for our previous two episodes on the build-up to the Easter Rising. Well, I probably wouldn't have read it in the GPO, Tom, to be honest. I'm brave,
在那面旗帜下，必须展示忠诚的心应如何向英国最古老的敌人屈服。我们知道每一处宁静家园所面临的战争准备。我们知道罗马（天主教会）的追随者们所宣称的地狱。市场、炉边和田野间的恐怖、威胁与恐惧。我们深知，一旦屈服，我们必将灭亡。请相信我们不敢吹嘘。请相信我们并不畏惧。我们准备为人们珍视的一切付出代价。北方有何回应？一个法律，一片土地，一个王座。如果英国……这首诗《阿尔斯特》由鲁德亚德·吉卜林创作，并于1912年4月9日发表在《晨邮报》上。这不仅是吉卜林的战斗号角吗？他代表了他眼中的英国火焰守护者——阿尔斯特人民，或者用我们现在的话说，也就是最终成为北爱尔兰这个国家、小国或省份的地方，随你怎么称呼它。所以我们现在身处这里，一场内战即将来临。确实如此，多米尼克。我想听众们能听出来，我们现在离都柏林的邮政总局（GPO）很远了，那是我们前两集讨论复活节起义前奏时所在的地方。好吧，老实说，汤姆，我可能不会在邮政总局读这首诗。我很勇敢，
but not that brave. So to explain, to remind listeners, we've done two episodes in Dublin with Paul Rouse, and now we're taking a break. By magic, we have left, we have spirited ourselves away from the GPO, and we are now back, where are we? We're back in England. We're back in Liverpool. We're back in Newcastle. We're back in the great cities of Britain. Edwardian Britain. Edwardian Britain. Because this story that we have framed as a story about Ireland is, of course, also a story about the other constituent parts of the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Ireland. And we shouldn't forget that.
但还没那么勇敢。所以，为了向听众解释和提醒，我们已经和保罗·劳斯在都柏林录了两集，现在我们要休息一下。通过魔法，我们离开了，我们从邮政总局瞬移走了，现在我们回来了，我们在哪儿？我们回到了英国。我们回到了利物浦。我们回到了纽卡斯尔。我们回到了英国的伟大城市。爱德华时代的英国。爱德华时代的英国。因为我们构建的这个关于爱尔兰的故事，当然也是关于大不列颠及爱尔兰联合王国其他组成部分的故事。我们不应该忘记这一点。
No, we shouldn't, Tom. I mean, we left last time. So those of you who listened to our first two episodes in this series will know that we left last time with Paul Rouse from University College Dublin, saying very firmly that at the beginning of the 1910s, the United Kingdom was, in his view, heading for civil war, and the Great War interrupts it. And of course, we know there wasn't a civil war, but today's episode is about that civil war that never was. And we're joined, Tom, by one of the great friends of the rest of history, aren't we? We are. So Dan Jackson, who has appeared on two episodes, he appeared on the episode we did on the North-South Divide. He appeared on the episode we did on the North-South Divide. He appeared on the episode
不，我们不应该忘记，汤姆。我的意思是，我们上次离开时……所以那些听过我们本系列前两集的听众会知道，我们上次离开时，都柏林大学学院的保罗·劳斯非常坚定地说，在1910年代初，在他看来，联合王国正走向内战，而大战（第一次世界大战）中断了它。当然，我们知道并没有发生内战，但今天的节目就是关于那场从未发生的内战。汤姆，我们邀请到了一位《历史的余味》的老朋友，对吧？是的。丹·杰克逊，他已经参加过两集节目了，他参加了我们关于南北差异的那一集。他参加了我们关于南北差异的那一集。他参加了我们关于
we did on the beginnings of the railways. He is probably best known for his wonderful, wonderful book, The Northumbrians, about the history and culture of the Northeast, which I know both of us nominated as History Book of the Year back when it was published. But Dan has also published another book. And that book has the very, very promising title of Popular Opposition to Irish Home Rule in Edwardian Britain. And Dan, this was your doctoral subject. So we are absolutely now on your home territory. Thanks very much. And thanks for the invitation again. Yes. And this is, you know, I was saying to Dominic before, historians go on about their period. This is the best period. This is so fantastic. Such a gripping story. And it has so much resonance for today, actually. So I'm glad that my old thesis, published in 2009 by Liverpool University Press, and it's still available, is getting another airing. So Dan, let's do the background because in the previous episode, we were talking a lot about 19th century Ireland and about the pressures, the sense of distinctiveness, the growing pressures, the demands for home rule that were embodied by the Irish Parliamentary Party under John Redmond.
铁路起源的那一集。他最出名的作品可能是那本精彩绝伦的《诺森布里亚人》（The Northumbrians），讲述了东北部的历史和文化，我知道我们俩在它出版时都将其提名为年度历史书籍。但丹还出版了另一本书。那本书有一个非常有前途的标题：《爱德华时代英国对爱尔兰自治的民众反对》（Popular Opposition to Irish Home Rule in Edwardian Britain）。丹，这是你的博士课题。所以我们现在绝对是在你的主场。非常感谢。也再次感谢你的邀请。是的，正如我之前对多米尼克所说，历史学家总是喋喋不休地谈论他们研究的时期。这是最好的时期。太棒了。这是一个如此引人入胜的故事。而且它实际上对今天也有很多共鸣。所以我很高兴我的旧论文，由利物浦大学出版社于2009年出版，而且现在还能买到，能再次得到讨论。那么丹，让我们先讲讲背景，因为在上一集中，我们谈了很多关于19世纪爱尔兰的问题，以及压力、独特性感、日益增长的压力，以及约翰·雷德蒙领导的爱尔兰议会党所体现的对自治的需求。
The Liberals under Gladstone had floated home rule. Gladstone had split his own party about it in the 1880s. Then they'd had another go in the 1890s, frustrated by the House of Lords. But things all change at the end of the 1900s, don't they? Can you give us a bit of a reminder of what's changed? Yeah. So before we get into the politics, I think there's something to be said about our general impressions about the Edwardian period. People look back kind of fondly to it. I guess it's the Downton Abbey era for some people.
格莱斯顿领导的自由党曾提出过自治。格莱斯顿在1880年代因此分裂了自己的政党。然后在1890年代，他们又尝试了一次，但受到上议院的阻挠。但在1900年代末，情况发生了变化，不是吗？你能提醒我们一下发生了什么变化吗？是的。所以在我们进入政治之前，我认为关于我们对爱德华时代的普遍印象，有些话要说。人们对它有一种怀旧之情。我想对某些人来说，这是《唐顿庄园》时代。
It's the Indian summer, Delhi-Durbar, Henley-Regatta. It's cricket at the Oval. It's the Kaiser at Cowes. Yeah, the Philip Larkin poem. Yes, it's all that sort of thing. It's also an era when Newcastle United are regularly champions of England. So it's a golden age. A golden age. A golden age.
这是印度之夏、德里杜尔巴、亨利赛艇会。这是在椭圆球场的板球比赛。这是在考斯的德皇。是的，菲利普·拉金的诗。是的，就是那种感觉。这也是纽卡斯尔联队经常成为英格兰冠军的时代。所以这是一个黄金时代。一个黄金时代。一个黄金时代。
In many respects. But actually, once you delve into the period, you realise that the country is, certainly by 1914, the story we're going to tell, is having a nervous breakdown. And you see traces of that in the debates that rage around the turn of the century, that sense of foreboding that people have. You know, Kipling's poem, Recessional, you know, we are masters of the universe, or are we? Or are there threats looming over the horizon? Are we as confident and prosperous and impregnable as we once were? And that plays out in the political field through a slightly dry topic of tariff reform, which emerges as a conservative policy idea pushed by Joseph Chamberlain, of course, a conservative politician at the time. And it's the idea that basically we can adjust
在许多方面。但实际上，一旦你深入研究这个时期，你就会意识到，到1914年，也就是我们要讲的故事发生时，这个国家正处于精神崩溃的边缘。你在世纪之交围绕那些激烈辩论中可以看到这种迹象，人们有一种不祥的预感。你知道，吉卜林的诗《退场》（Recessional），你知道，我们是宇宙的主宰，或者我们是吗？还是说地平线上有威胁在逼近？我们是否像曾经那样自信、繁荣和坚不可摧？这在政治领域通过关税改革这个略显枯燥的话题表现出来，它作为一种保守党政策理念出现，当然是由当时的保守党政治家约瑟夫·张伯伦推动的。其基本理念是我们能够调整
our tariff barriers to better protect our empire and encourage industrial growth in the empire and also prosperity at home. But this is a massively controversial subject for a country that had set out its store politically for decades around free trade and that had driven much of Britain's prosperity and so for although after the 1860s when Gladstone has his unfortunate period of trying to get home rule through parliament and fails the Tories capitalise on that the in 1886 of course Rand, a leading Conservative, is described as having played the orange card in his support for or opposition to Irish Home Rule. There's about two decades of Tory hegemony until the 1906 general election, which is a Liberal landslide. And there's no sense of Irish Home Rule being on the Liberal Party's agenda in that period. Because it doesn't need to be, because the Irish Parliamentary Party are not holding the balance of power. They need to hold the balance of power to have any influence.
我们的关税壁垒，以更好地保护我们的帝国，并鼓励帝国的工业增长以及国内的繁荣。但对于一个几十年来在政治上以自由贸易为基础，并以此推动了英国大部分繁荣的国家来说，这是一个极具争议的话题。因此，尽管在1860年代之后，当格莱斯顿经历了试图在议会通过自治法案却失败的不幸时期，保守党人利用了这一点，当然在1886年，保守党领袖伦道夫勋爵被描述为在支持或反对爱尔兰自治时打了“橙色牌”。直到1906年大选，自由党大获全胜，保守党经历了大约二十年的霸权。在那段时期，爱尔兰自治并没有被列入自由党的议程。因为没必要，因为爱尔兰议会党并没有掌握权力平衡。他们需要掌握权力平衡才能产生任何影响。
But also, even so the Liberals are associated with the Home Rule cause. But one thing I hadn't really gauged until you and I, Tom, both read this book, Fatal Path, by a brilliant Irish historian, Ronan Fanning, was the extent to which even in the Liberal Party, which is, as it were, the more sympathetic to Irish home rule, the people running that party are fervently anti-Catholic and have an enormous dislike of Ireland and the Irish, Asquith, Lloyd George especially. I mean, Lloyd George, non-conformist, he thinks Catholic priests are the devil incarnate. He has no time for Ireland. He thinks, you know, it's just a sort of much worse Wales.
但即便如此，自由党还是与自治事业联系在一起。但有一件事，在我和你，汤姆，都读了爱尔兰杰出历史学家罗南·范宁的《致命路径》（Fatal Path）这本书之前，我并没有真正意识到，即使是在自由党内部——也就是对爱尔兰自治更同情的政党——那些管理该党的人也是狂热的反天主教徒，对爱尔兰和爱尔兰人有着巨大的厌恶，尤其是阿斯奎斯和劳合·乔治。我的意思是，劳合·乔治，非国教徒，他认为天主教神父是恶魔的化身。他根本没时间理会爱尔兰。他认为，你知道，那只是一个糟糕得多的威尔士。
You know, I hadn't gauged. I'd always thought there'd been some sentimental fondness for Ireland in the Liberal Party. But no, they couldn't give a damn about Ireland, could they, Dan? Certainly not. And even when, you know, Asquith eventually becomes Premier in 1908, Asquith's too busy, you know, drinking port, playing bridge and basically texting his various girlfriends because he corresponded with them so frequently to care a damn about Ireland. What changes? First, they have the liberal landslide, but that majority's nibbled away in the course of the controversies around the people's budget and so on in 1909 in
你知道，我没预料到。我一直以为自由党内对爱尔兰有一种感伤的喜爱。但没有，他们根本不在乎爱尔兰，对吧，丹？当然不在乎。即使当，你知道，阿斯奎斯最终在1908年成为首相时，阿斯奎斯太忙了，你知道，喝波特酒、打桥牌，基本上是在给他的各个女朋友发短信，因为他与她们通信太频繁了，根本不在乎爱尔兰。发生了什么变化？首先，他们在大选中大获全胜，但随着1909年围绕人民预算等问题的争议，多数席位被蚕食，
the Confrontational House of Lords. There are two general elections in 1910 in which basically the Liberals lose their majority. They still want to push forward their social program. And the price of that that the Irish Nationalist Party extract from them is, let's go back to home rule. We want home rule in return for supporting the program of the Liberal government and getting it through Parliament. And now there's a plausible chance the Home Rule can pass because, as we were talking with Paul last time, there's been this huge parliamentary reform which has removed the veto power of the House of Lords. So now, instead of blocking something, the House of Lords can only delay it by two years. You have to keep the legislation unchanged, don't you? Unamended.
在对抗性的上议院中。1910年举行了两次大选，自由党基本上失去了多数席位。他们仍然想推进他们的社会计划。而爱尔兰民族党从他们那里榨取的代价是，让我们回到自治问题。我们想要自治，以换取支持自由党政府的计划并使其在议会通过。现在自治有通过的可能了，因为正如我们上次和保罗谈到的，进行了巨大的议会改革，取消了上议院的否决权。所以现在，上议院不能再阻止某事，只能将其推迟两年。你必须保持立法不变，对吧？未经修改。
And the third time you introduce it, it will pass the House of Lords and it's through. And the Conservatives, am I right, that the Conservatives see this as, I mean, they're going on all the time about the Liberals as a revolutionary committee, aren't they? I mean, they haven't coined the phrase Bolsheviks, but they basically see the Liberals as people who are blowing up the constitution just to stay in office yeah this is a vastly controversial move on behalf of the liberals but they had to do something because their legislative program was consistently blocked in the tory dominated house of lords this was the last era when the landed interest had you know a huge political influence still
第三次提出时，它就会在上议院通过，从而获得通过。保守党人，我说的对吗，他们认为自由党是一个革命委员会，对吧？我的意思是，他们还没创造出“布尔什维克”这个词，但他们基本上认为自由党人是为了保住职位而炸毁宪法的人。是的，这是自由党方面一个极具争议的举措，但他们必须采取行动，因为他们的立法计划一直受到保守党控制的上议院的阻挠。这是土地利益仍然拥有巨大政治影响力的最后一个时代，
in great britain and they consistently did that. And they confronted the House of Lords over it. And they pushed through the Parliament Act in 1911, which basically removed the veto of the House of Lords from legislation that came from the Commons. And that opened the way to, because of course, in the 1880s, Gladstone had the numbers to get home rule
在英国，他们一直这样做。他们为此与上议院对抗。他们在1911年强行通过了《议会法案》，该法案基本上取消了上议院对下议院立法的否决权。这为自治铺平了道路，因为当然，在1880年代，格莱斯顿有足够的票数让自治法案在下议院通过，但无法通过上议院。所以这是一个真正的游戏规则改变者。大卫·劳合·乔治在纽卡斯尔的一次演讲中说，你知道，自由党政府正试图为建造无畏舰等庞大的军备计划买单，他说，你知道，一个公爵的造价相当于两艘无畏舰，而且寿命是其两倍。这在英国政治史上几乎是闻所未闻的，竟然对旧贵族有如此的嘲讽和对抗。所以很多保守党人为此失去了理智。其中一些人被称为“挖沟者”（ditchers），因为他们准备为
through the House of Commons, but not through the House of Lords. So this was a was a real game changer and you've got David Lloyd George and it famously in a speech in Newcastle saying you know but the Liberal government are trying to pay for the massive armament program of building dreadnoughts and so on and he says you know a duke costs as much as two dreadnoughts and lasts twice as long this is unheard of almost in British political history for that to be such ridicule and confrontation with the old aristocracy. And so a lot of Tories lose their minds over this. And some of them are called the ditchers because they're prepared to die in a ditch over
上议院改革而死在沟里。但一旦爱尔兰民族党在两次大选后的谈判取得进展，道路似乎就清晰了，或者也许不是，但重新引入自治法案的道路似乎是清晰的。所以丹，如果保守党人认为自由党人是危险的、颠覆性的、共产主义者，无论什么，这种恐惧大概开始使保守党激进化了。他们现在有两个巨大的事业。他们对上议院发生的事情感到非常不安，即上议院阻止自由党立法的能力被削弱。所以这是他们非常不安的一件事。但现在，迫在眉睫的是爱尔兰自治问题，这现在看起来是一个非常、非常实际的
Lord's reform. But once the negotiations of the Irish Nationalist Party proceed after those two general elections, the way the path is clear, or maybe it isn't, but the path seems to be clear to reintroduce a home rule bill. So Dan, if the Tories see the Liberals as kind of dangerous, subversives, communists, whatever, that fear presumably starts to radicalise the Tories. And they have two massive causes now. They're deeply upset about what's happened to the House of Lords, the degradation of the ability of the Lords to block liberal legislation. So that's one thing they're very upset about. But now, Hoving interview is the issue of what Irish home rule, which now seems a very, very practical
可能性。确实，它已经通过了，不是吗？已经立法了。这对大英帝国意味着什么？当然，绝对是。正如我们将要看到的，爱尔兰，特别是爱尔兰北部，被视为大英帝国的缩影。有些人将爱尔兰描述为英国的第一个殖民地。所以这是大英帝国盔甲上的第一个裂缝。当然，这紧随所有关于我们如何最好地巩固全球统治地位的辩论之后，关税改革是答案吗？这些辩论在这一时期的保守党内部实际上仍在进行。也许我们可以再尝试一次关税改革。然后爱尔兰自治问题又回到了议程上。
possibility. Indeed, it's been passed, hasn't it? It's been legislated for. What are the implications of that for the British Empire? Of course, absolutely. And as we shall see, Ireland, especially the north of Ireland, is seen to represent the British Empire in microcosm. Some people describe Ireland as England struck Britain's first colony. And so this is the first kind of chink in the armour of the British Empire. This comes hot on the heels, of course, of all these debates about how do we best shore up our global dominance? Is tariff reform the answer? And those debates are still actually playing out within the Tory party in this period. Maybe we can have another go at tariff reform. And then the Irish Home Rule issue is back on the agenda.
这是否起到了某种统一议题的作用？我的意思是，这就是他们支持它的部分原因吗？是的。但我认为这一时期保守党政治最决定性的因素是领导层的更迭。因为当然，在保守党霸权的岁月里，是索尔兹伯里勋爵。他传位给他的侄子亚瑟·贝尔福。当然，这就是“鲍勃是你叔叔”（Bob's your uncle）这个短语的由来。但亚瑟·贝尔福是一个非常不同的人物。他是一个伦敦沙龙里的人。他是个单身汉。他在牛津大学的绰号是“漂亮的范妮”（Pretty Fanny）。丹，你知道我最喜欢的贝尔福格言吗？说来听听。那就是：没什么事很重要，很少有事有任何意义。是的，所以他并不是保守党所需要的那种充满活力的领导人。他不会死在沟里。
And does that serve as a kind of unifying issue? I mean, is that part of why they pile in behind it? It is. But I think the most decisive factor for particularly Conservative Party's politics in this period is a change of leadership. Because, of course, in the years of Tory hegemony, it's Lord Salisbury. He passes on to his nephew, Arthur Balfour. Hence the phrase, Bob's your uncle, of course. But Arthur Balfour is a very different character. He's a man of the kind of the salons of London. He's a bachelor. His nickname at Oxford University was Pretty Fanny. Do you know my favourite Balfour aphorism, Dan? Go on. Which is to say, nothing matters very much and few things matter at all yes so he wasn't exactly the dynamic leader that the tories needed he's not going to die in a ditch
他不会死在沟里。所以他们四处寻找，进行了一些内部辩论，他们选出的领导人是安德鲁·博纳·劳（Andrew Bonar Law），在鲍里斯·约翰逊出现之前，他是唯一一位出生在联合王国之外的英国首相，因为他在1920年代成为首相。他出生在新不伦瑞克，新不伦瑞克偏远地区的一位长老会牧师家中。他有阿尔斯特和苏格兰背景。这就是关键。这是这里的关键因素。我正想说，丹，这就是关键，不是吗？
he's not going to die in a ditch so they cast around a bit and they have some internal debates and the man they come up with as their leader is andrew bonner law who until boris johnson came along was the only british prime minister because he becomes prime minister in the 1920s, to be born outside of the United Kingdom. He was born in New Brunswick, the back of beyond New Brunswick to a Presbyterian minister. And he's got this Ulster and Scottish background. And that's the key. That's the key factor here. I was about to say, Dan, that's the key, isn't it?
因为我开头读了那首吉卜林的诗《阿尔斯特》。汤姆，在所有这些讨论中，我们还没有谈论太多关于爱尔兰岛北部的情况。对。所以这就是关键，不是吗？但保罗描述了种植园。所以在16和17世纪，所有这些定居者到达，包括克伦威尔的军队，他们是狂热的新教徒，通常有苏格兰血统。而他们，丹，我的意思是，这就是问题变得，可以说，煽动性，有时甚至是字面上的煽动性，因为他们集中在爱尔兰岛的东北角。他们中的一些人，许多人可以追溯他们的，你知道，他们现在不是定居者了，他们可以追溯
Because I opened with that Kipling poem, Ulster. And we haven't, in all of this, Tom, we haven't talked very much about the situation in the north of the island of Ireland. Right. So that's the key thing, isn't it? But Paul described the plantations. So in the 16th and 17th century, all these settlers arriving, including Cromwell's troops, who are fervently Protestant, often of Scottish heritage. And they, Dan, I mean, this is where the issue becomes, as it were, incendiary, sometimes literally incendiary, because they are concentrated in the northeastern corner of the island of Ireland. Some of them, many of them can trace their, you know, they're not settlers now, they can trace
他们的血统可以追溯到几个世纪前，不是吗？我的意思是，就他们而言，他们已经建立了，我的意思是，吉卜林在这首诗中说，他们想在播种的地方收获。他们创造了这个世界，他们对爱尔兰自治感到恐惧，因为他们认为他们将被爱尔兰岛上的天主教多数派统治。那是对的，不是吗？完全正确。
their lineage back centuries, can't they? I mean, as far as they're not settlers now, they can trace their lineage back centuries, can't they? I mean, as far as they're concerned, they've built, I mean, Kipling says in this sort of poem, they want to reap where they had sown. They had created this world and they are terrified of Irish home rule because they think they will be governed by a Catholic majority on the island of Ireland. That's right, isn't it? Completely.
正如我知道你在本播客的不同主题中多次讨论过的那样，我们有必要回到一个宗教信仰方式仍然非常重要的时代。因为我认为，在第一次世界大战之前，这基本上是宗教在英国政治史上仍然重要的最后一次，因为它围绕着阿尔斯特的事业而凝聚，不被视为背叛这些忠诚的新教臣民，并将他们交给——正如人们所认为的那样——一个不忠诚的罗马天主教徒。这仍然是一个对罗马天主教徒的偏见巨大、普遍且往往是暴力的时代，这让人们感到震惊。这让保守党内部的人感到震惊。但那个将这种愤怒转化为政治纲领的人是安德鲁·博纳·劳。他被称为“博纳”（Bonar）。这是他的中间名，所以他被称为博纳·劳。当时报纸上称他为“劳”。这不是一个双重姓氏。但他在这里绝对是至关重要的，因为他是如此强硬，他是一位前格拉斯哥钢铁商人，他曾在格拉斯哥和利物浦担任议员，而这两个城市基本上是英国最具有宗派主义色彩的城市，所以他知道这个问题在爱德华时代的街头政治中能引发的情绪。而这基本上是保守党一直在寻找的用来对抗自由党的实质性议题，一个能赢得选票的议题。这就是他们所确定的。这就是未来几年情况的发展方式。
And as I know you've discussed on many occasions on different topics on this podcast, it's important for us to get back into the mindset of an era when debates about how you did Christianity were still really important. Because this is basically the last time that religion matters in British political history, I would argue, before the First World War, because it coalesces around the cause of Ulster and not being seen to betray these loyal Protestant subjects and hand them over, as it's seen, to a disloyal and Roman Catholic. And this is still an era when prejudice against Roman Catholics is massive, widespread, and very often violent, it dumbfounds people. It dumbfounds people in the Tory party. But the guy who galvanizes that anger
但对于劳，或者我的意思是，我知道人们现在叫他“博纳劳”，当时人们叫他“劳”。这不仅仅是一个愤世嫉俗的策略，对吧？我的意思是，我想他失去了父亲，他父亲搬回了北爱尔兰。他花了很多时间去探望他的父亲。传记作者说，当他父亲去世时，他悲痛欲绝。他发誓要维护他父亲的遗产，所有这些东西。我的意思是，对于博纳劳来说，正如你所说，他是一个非常强硬的人，相当严肃的人。哦，非常如此。
into a political program is Andrew Bonner Law. He's known as Bonner. It was his middle name, so he's known as Bonner Law. He's described as Law in the papers at the time. It wasn't a double-barreled name. But he's absolutely critical here because he is so hardcore he's a former Glasgow iron merchant he's been an MP in Glasgow and Liverpool and they're basically the two most sectarian cities in Britain so he knows the emotions that this issue can can cause on kind of Edwardian street politics and And this is basically the issue that the Tory party had been casting around for a substantive issue to confront the Liberals with, a vote winner. This is what they settle on. And this is how it plays out for the next few years.
这真的是非常、非常充满激情的，不是吗？完全是。我不想给人留下这仅仅是一个愤世嫉俗的策略的印象，因为这对人们来说很重要。但博纳劳以一种我认为像亚瑟·贝尔福这样的人无法真正看到这种激情可能引发的方式发现了这一点。但它确实需要有人来煽动愤怒的火焰。正是通过博纳劳的工作，与阿尔斯特统一派的领导层紧密合作，正如我们将要讨论的那样，这确实使这个国家在第一次世界大战爆发时非常接近一场大火。所以丹，你提到了阿尔斯特统一派的领导层。所以我们一直在听爱尔兰议会党，自治的热情支持者，我的意思是，他们的全部意义在于他们是议会制的，他们是通过宪法手段工作的。是的。阿尔斯特统一派是否有宪法途径，有阻止自治的可能性，还是他们绝对决心推动它，甚至达到暴力的程度，即建立准军事反对派？基本上是的，因为
But for law, or I mean, I know people call him Bonaraw now, by the time he said people called him law. It's not just a cynical manoeuvre, is it? I mean, he'd lost his father, I think his father had moved back to Northern Ireland. He had spent a lot of time traveling to see his father. He was, biographers sort of say, when his father died, he was prostrate with grief. He swore to uphold his father's legacy, all of this stuff. I mean, for Bonalor, who, as you said, is a really hard man, quite a doer man. Oh, very much so.
他们可以看到《议会法案》颁布后的逻辑，即1911年后不再有上议院作为他们的堡垒来保护他们了。所以当1912年4月11日，赫伯特·阿斯奎斯向议会提交第三份自治法案时，他们知道大限将至。现在阻碍它的议会障碍非常有限。所以他们开始在各个方面进行动员。他们做的第一件事就是选择了一个叫爱德华·卡森爵士的人作为他们的领袖。现在，卡森是一个绝对迷人的人物。他现在可能更出名，因为他在法律界有着辉煌的职业生涯。他可能是该国薪水最高的出庭律师之一，在那个时期是百万富翁。
This is really, really passionate kind of stuff, isn't it? It is completely. I don't want to give the impression that it was just a cynical maneuver by any means, because this was important to people. But Bonaloh spotted this in a way that someone like Arthur Balfour, I would suggest, couldn't really see the passions that this could engender and did. But it did require someone to stoke the flames of anger. And it was through the work of Bonalor, working hand in glove with the
他处理了一系列非常著名的案件。不过，最著名的一个大概是1895年他为昆斯伯里侯爵辩护，对抗奥斯卡·王尔德的诽谤指控。因为他们以前在学校里就在一起，不是吗，在都柏林？他们一起去了都柏林三一学院。他们都来自那个盎格鲁-爱尔兰的都柏林世界。有趣的是，爱德华·卡森是都柏林大学的统一派议员，因为这仍然是顶级大学向议会派遣议员的时代。所以牛津和剑桥、苏格兰大学、伦敦大学学院和都柏林大学各派遣两名议员，卡森就是其中之一。因为都柏林在这个时期，我的意思是，你探索过它。它在许多方面是一个乔治亚风格的城市。它是都柏林城堡所在地，而且它仍然是一个相当统一派的城市。
leadership of the Ulster Unionists, as we'll go on to discuss, that really tipped this country very closely towards a conflagration on the outbreak of the First World War. So Dan, you mentioned there the leadership of the Ulster Unionists. So we've been hearing how the Irish Parliamentary Party, Enthusiasts for Home Rule, I mean, the whole point of them is that they are parliamentary, they are working through constitutional means. Yes. Do the Ulster Unionists have a constitutional approach, a possibility of blocking home rule, or are they absolutely set on pushing it even to the degree of violence, of kind of setting up paramilitary opposition? Basically, yes, because
在许多方面。有一个爱尔兰侮辱性词汇偶尔被用来称呼都柏林人，叫他们“杰基恩”（Jackines），据说是因为他们挥舞联合杰克旗（Union Jacks），或者至少过去是这样。如果你看1918年都柏林停战的照片，到处都是联合杰克旗。但那段历史很快就改变了。但这就是卡森的出身。他来自那个世界，他是一位出色的公众演说家。与这一时期阿尔斯特统一派领导层的大部分人相比，他是一个非常有魅力的人物。非常上镜。他有突出的下巴，你知道，巨大的秃头。他穿着非常考究。他经常戴着康乃馨，扣眼，洪堡帽。他是一个非常威严的人物。他被请来，卡森余生一直是一位爱尔兰统一派。他来自都柏林。在卡森的理想世界中，整个爱尔兰都会作为联邦的一部分保留下来。
they can see the logic of the Parliament Act having been enacted, that there isn't the House of Lords bulwark to protect them anymore after 1911. So when, on 11th of April 1912, Herbert Asquith introduces the third Home Rule Bill to Parliament, they know that the writing's on the wall. There are very limited parliamentary obstacles in its way now. And so they start to mobilize in every possible sense. And one of the first things they do is that they select a man called Sir Edward Carson as their leader. Now, Carson is an absolutely fascinating figure. He's probably better known these days because he had a glittering career in the law. He's probably one of the best paid barristers in the country, millionaire
但人们意识到这根本是不可能的。所以爱尔兰的大多数统一派都集中在阿尔斯特，显然。好吧，实际上是阿尔斯特的远东北角，而不是整个历史省份。所以那种围绕阿尔斯特的集中，在19世纪有着非常不同的发展路径。你1900年去贝尔法斯特，它看起来像纽卡斯尔或格拉斯哥或英格兰北部的一个城市。它是工业化的。它围绕造船、亚麻和工程等建立。它拥有一个非常强大、繁荣、自信的新教工人阶级和中产阶级。他们对被都柏林统治的想法感到恐惧。是的，博纳劳说过类似的话。我前几天偶然发现的，当他来回旅行去探望他父亲时，我想是这样，他被它看起来像一个英格兰北部或苏格兰城市所震撼。他说，你会把
in that period. He took on a range of very famous cases. Probably the most famous one, though, was when he defended the Marquess of Queensbury against Oscar Wilde's accusation of libel in 1895, I think it was. Because they'd been at school together, hadn't they, in Dublin? They'd gone to Trinity College Dublin together. They both came from that Anglo-Irish ascendancy Dublin world. And interestingly, Edward Carson is the unionist MP for Dublin University, because this is still the era when the top universities sent MPs to Parliament. So Oxford and Cambridge, the Scottish universities, UCL and Dublin University sent two MPs and Carson was one of them. Because Dublin in this period, I mean, you explored it. It's a Georgian city in many respects. It's where Dublin Castle is located and it's still a pretty unionist
利物浦、谢菲尔德、曼彻斯特交给罗马吗？不，当然不会。这对他来说显然非常重要。但我还要问的另一件事是，所以卡森是一位伟大的表演者，是一位出庭律师，他是一个戏剧性的人。我的意思是，ACMI，229,000名男性和女性排队签署这份誓言，他们将使用一切必要手段来击败目前在爱尔兰建立自治议会的阴谋。对，所以一切必要手段。他们所说的“一切必要手段”是什么意思？是的，在这个时期，它仍然有点模糊。那到底是什么意思？我的意思是，有些人据传是用自己的血签署这份《阿尔斯特盟约》（Ulster Covenant）。他们对这件事的感觉是多么强烈。当然，它有故意的回响，
city in many respects. And there's an Irish insult that's occasionally used for Dubliners to call them Jackines, which is said to come from the fact that they wave Union Jacks around, or used to, at least. If you look at the armistice pictures from Dublin in 1918, there's just Union Jacks all over the place. But that history changed pretty quickly. But that's where Carson comes from. He comes from that world, and he's a brilliant public speaker. And he's such a charismatic figure in contrast to much of the kind of Ulster Unionist leadership in this period. Very photogenic. He's got the lantern jaw, you know, the enormous bald head. He's a very, he's a kind of dandified dress. He's often got the carnation, his buttonhole, the Homburg hat. He's a very imposing figure. And he's brought in, Carson remains for the rest of his life, an Irish unionist. He's from Dublin. In an ideal world for Carson, the whole of Ireland would have remained as part of the union.
17世纪的各种盟约，在苏格兰签署以反对查理一世的宗教改革、引入新祈祷书等等。这些人中的许多人可以将他们的祖先追溯到17世纪的苏格兰和英格兰北部。所以这有着巨大的情感共鸣。但在这一点上，直到1912年底在盛大的仪式中签署盟约之后，人们的思想很快转向了我们将采取什么实际步骤来抵制这项措施，他们很快在1913年初通过组建最初被称为“阿尔斯特志愿者”（Ulster Volunteers），后来被称为“阿尔斯特志愿军”（Ulster Volunteer Force），也许我会熟悉UVF，这是第二次成立。
But there comes a realization that that's just not possible. And so most of the unionists in Ireland are concentrated in Ulster, obviously. Well, actually, the far northeast corner of Ulster, not the whole of the historic province. And so that concentration around Ulster, which had a very different developmental path in the 19th century. You go to Belfast in 1900, it looks like Newcastle or Glasgow or a city in the north of England. It's industrial. It's built around shipbuilding and linen and engineering and all the rest of it. And it's got a very strong, prosperous, confident, Protestant working and middle class. And they're horrified at the thought of being governed from Dublin. Yeah, Bonalor said something like that. I came across it the other day, that when he was traveling back and forth to visit his father, I think it was, he was struck by how Northern, you know, what like a Northern English or Scottish city it was. He said, would you hand
UVF在1960年代后期，即动乱时期第二次成立。但阿尔斯特志愿军的这种最初表现形式确实是一个不同的野兽。它有更广泛的中产阶级参与。它来自已经存在的北爱尔兰民兵，利用了非常强大的盎格鲁-爱尔兰军事传统。如果你想想惠灵顿和蒙哥马利以及所有那些来自爱尔兰的人，阿尔斯特志愿军的组建在英国历史上几乎是前所未有的，竟然组建了一支如此大规模的军事、准军事力量来反对议会的一项法案。对。好吧。所以这对爱尔兰的稳定，甚至对整个联合王国来说看起来都不太好。所以我认为我们应该在这一点上休息一下。丹，当我们回来时，也许我们可以谈谈这支准军事力量的出现对英国政治在1914年8月之前的影响。
over, you know, Liverpool, Sheffield, Manchester to Rome? No, of course you wouldn't. And that clearly really matters to him. But the other thing I was going to ask about was, so Carson is a great performer, is a barrister, he's a theatrical man. And I mean, the ACMI, the high points of men and 229,000 women queue up to sign this pledge that they will use all means necessary to defeat the present conspiracy to set up a home rule parliament in Ireland. Right, so all means necessary. What do they mean by all means necessary? Yeah, at this period, it's still a bit ambiguous. What exactly does that mean? I mean, some people are signing, reputedly, are signing this Ulster Covenant in their own blood. That's how strongly they feel about this. And it's got deliberate echoes, of course,
我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。“我一直希望爱尔兰的天主教徒能够自我管理，”埃舍勋爵写信给玛戈·阿斯奎斯。“几个世纪以来，我们已经证明自己不适合管理一个天主教社区，但我们管理天主教徒的不适程度，远不及他们管理新教社区的不适程度。这就是局势的全部伦理和政治层面。”尽管这种公然的反天主教情绪很少被写在纸上，但它们影响了政府和反对派的心态。埃舍作为国王与大臣们的联络人，如果他不是确信她有同样的想法，他几乎不会以这种方式写信给首相的妻子。正如丹尼尔·杰克逊所观察到的，1912-14年的自治危机是宗教和政治在英国政治中最后一次严重交集。
of the 17th century, the various covenants that were subscribed to in Scotland to object to Charles I's religious reforms, introduction of new prayer books and all that sort of thing. And many of these people could trace their ancestry back to 17th century Scotland and Northern England. So this had enormous emotional resonance. But at this point, it isn't until after the covenant is signed amidst great ceremony in late 1912 that thoughts quickly turned to what practical steps are we going to take here to withstand this measure and they quickly move by the early months of 1913 by the formation of what was originally called the ulster volunteers then became known as the ulster volunteer force maybe i'll be familiar with the uF, which was the second founding.
所以那是罗南·范宁，多米尼克，你在上半场提到的，是《致命路径》的作者。他是都柏林大学学院的现代史教授，也就是保罗·劳斯的大学。而他提到的那个丹尼尔·杰克逊，丹，就是你。是的，很高兴听到这个。我多年前见过罗南·范宁，他在那本书《致命路径》里。他太棒了。
The UVF was founded for a second time in the 1960s, late 60s, during the Troubles period. But this initial manifestation of the Ulster Volunteers was a different beast, really. It had much more widespread middle-class participation. It was drawn from the militias of Northern Ireland that existed already, played into the very strong Anglo-Irish martial tradition. If you think about Wellington and Montgomery and all them who came from Ireland, the formation of the Ulster Volunteers is almost unprecedented in British history to have such a large scale military, paramilitary force formed in opposition to a bill in Parliament. Right. Okay. So this isn't looking good for the stability of Ireland or indeed for the United Kingdom as a whole. So I think we should take a break at this point. And Dan, when we come back, perhaps we can talk about what effect the emergence of this paramilitary force
但我认为丹尼尔·杰克逊是对的。他很出色，不是吗？真是一位学者。我认为这是一个人们仍然认真对待新教统治的时代，你在最近的加冕典礼上看到了这一点，国王必须宣誓维护新教改革宗教、苏格兰教会的治理以及所有这些事务，这对我们来说似乎有点刺耳。但在当时，我们已经看到宗教与政治的交集是多么重要。我的意思是，在爱尔兰自治法案通过的同时，《威尔士教会废除国教法案》（Welsh Church Disestablishment Bill）也在遭到大规模敌对反对的情况下被强行通过。天哪，这简直是屠杀。丹，让我们深入探讨一下。所以这是，你知道，1910年代初。尽管爱德华时代对布尔战争和民族堕落以及所有这些随之而来的事情感到不安，但英国仍然非常清楚地是世界上领先的帝国大国。我的意思是，它正在受到挑战，但它在某种程度上仍然是顶级国家。人们有，你知道，电力正在进入，留声机，人们正在去电影院，所有这些事情。令人震惊的是，在联合王国的大不列颠本身，
has on British politics in the build-up to August 1914. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. I have always wished the Catholics in Ireland to govern themselves, wrote Lord Esher to Margot Asquith. We have shown ourselves unfit to govern a community of Catholics, this over centuries, but we are not half as unfit to govern Catholics as they are to govern the Protestant community. That is the whole ethical and political aspect of the situation. Although such flagrantly anti-Catholic sentiments were rarely committed to paper, they coloured the mentality of government and opposition. Esher, as the king's liaison with ministers, moreover, would scarcely have written in such
到处都有人，他们住在郊区的别墅里，读着《每日电讯报》或《每日邮报》或什么的，或者《泰晤士报》，他们对自己说，你知道，天主教统治对北爱尔兰的这些可怜人来说将是可怕的。我们不能，你知道，显然罗马是，我的意思是，这就是所有政治家，自由党和保守党，所想的。关于这个问题，是什么让它如此具有煽动性，如此有毒，并对人们对英国是什么和意味着什么的认知构成如此大的威胁？嗯，我认为它结合了许多非常有趣的点。首先，联合、帝国和新教基督教的中心地位
terms to the prime minister's wife were he not satisfied that she was of like mind. The home rule crisis of 1912-14, as Daniel Jackson has observed, was the last time that religion and politics seriously intersected in British politics. So that was Ronan Fanning, who, Dominic, you mentioned in the first half, author of Fatal Path. He was Professor of Modern History at University College Dublin, which is Paul Rouse's university. And the Daniel Jackson that he mentions there, Dan, is you. Yes, well, delighted to hear that. And I met Ronan Fanning many years ago, and he was in that book, The Fatal Path. He's fantastic.
在爱德华时代英国民族认同的矩阵中仍然非常重要。我认为这仍然是漫长的19世纪的终结。我认为第一次世界大战是一个分水岭。第一次世界大战后情况确实发生了巨大变化，但它们还没有改变。英国和爱尔兰的普通民众仍然可以被这些古老的怨恨和恐惧所激励。而且这仍然是一个对天主教普遍存在广泛的屈尊俯就和敌意的时期。对天主教普遍，特别是对爱尔兰天主教徒。现在，我有时认为英国是一个移民国家的说法往往被夸大了。如果有的话，英国更多时候是一个
But I think that Daniel Jackson's right. He's brilliant, isn't he? What a scholar. I think this is an era when people take seriously still the kind of Protestant ascendancy, which you saw in the coronation recently, where the king had to pledge to uphold the Protestant reformed religion, the governance of the Church of Scotland and all this business, which seemed slightly jarring to us. But back then, we've seen it's incredibly important how religion intersected with politics. I mean, at the same time as the Irish Home Rule Bill is going through, the Welsh Church Disestablishment Bill is also being pushed through in the teeth of
移民输出国。它一直是一个人口输出国。有时我们对自己关于英国移民的叙述，特别是忽略了爱尔兰移民，这是巨大的。这为这些问题增添了另一种尖锐性，这些问题从1500年代末开始就是英国民族认同的基础，当时你在19世纪大量涌入，不仅仅是在饥荒时期，尽管那极大地扩大了人数，但在整个19世纪和20世纪初，大量爱尔兰天主教徒进入了英国，特别是城市英国。并且存在一种针对他们的反弹投票。这是一个典型的故事。我们不喜欢你们的宗教。我们不喜欢你们来到这里抢走我们的工作并降低我们的工资的事实。我们也不喜欢你们不忠诚的事实。你们在布尔战争期间为布尔人欢呼。从都柏林出发就像把福克兰群岛交给阿根廷或把直布罗陀交给西班牙。这对人们来说将是令人震惊的。什么？这就是你们的回报方式吗？
massively hostile opposition. God, it's carnage. Dan, let's get into this. So this is, you know, the early 1910s. Britain is, for all the jitteriness about the Boer War and national degeneracy and all this sort of carry on that you get in the Edwardian period, Britain is still very clearly the world's leading imperial power. I mean, it's being challenged, but it's kind of just about still top nation. People have, you know, electricity is coming in, gramophones, people are going to the cinema, all of these kinds of things. What the astounding thing is that there are people all over the United Kingdom in Great Britain
极其敌对的反对。天哪，简直是一场大屠杀。丹，让我们深入探讨一下。所以，这是在1910年代初期。尽管爱德华时代人们对布尔战争和民族堕落等问题感到不安，但英国显然仍然是世界领先的帝国强国。我的意思是，它虽然受到了挑战，但基本上仍然是头号强国。人们有了电力、留声机，开始去电影院，所有这些事物都在出现。令人震惊的是，在整个联合王国和英国各地，都有人
itself, who are living in their kind of suburban villas, reading the Daily Telegraph or the Daily Mail or whatever, or the Times, and they are saying to themselves, you know, Catholic rule would be awful for these poor people in Northern Ireland. We can't, you know, obviously Rome is, I mean, this is what all the politicians, Liberal as well as Tory, think. What is it about this issue that is so incendiary, that is so toxic and so threatening to people's sense of what Britain is and means? Well, I think it combines a number of really interesting points. Firstly, the centrality of the Union, the Empire, and Protestant Christianity
住在他们的郊区别墅里，读着《每日电讯报》、《每日邮报》或《泰晤士报》之类的报纸，他们对自己说，你知道，天主教统治对北爱尔兰那些可怜的人来说将是可怕的。我们不能，显然罗马是，我的意思是，这就是所有政治家，无论是自由党还是保守党，所想的。这个问题究竟有什么如此煽动性、如此有毒，以至于威胁到人们对英国是什么及其意义的认知？嗯，我认为它结合了许多非常有趣的观点。首先，联合、帝国和新教基督教的核心地位
in the matrix of Edwardian British national identity is still really important. I think this is still the end of a long 19th century. I think the First World War is a watershed. Things do change massively after the First World War, but they hadn't changed yet. And the ordinary people in Britain and Ireland could still be motivated by these ancient grievances and fears and so on. And it's still a period where there's widespread condescension and hostility towards Catholicism. Catholicism in general and Irish Catholics in particular. Now, I sometimes think that the story of Britain being a nation of immigrants is often overdone. If anything, Britain's most often been
在爱德华时代英国民族认同的矩阵中仍然非常重要。我认为这仍然是漫长的19世纪的终结。我认为第一次世界大战是一个分水岭。第一次世界大战后，情况发生了巨大的变化，但当时还没有改变。英国和爱尔兰的普通民众仍然会被这些古老的怨恨和恐惧所驱使。而且，那仍然是一个对天主教普遍存在屈尊俯就和敌意的时期。对天主教普遍如此，对爱尔兰天主教徒尤其如此。现在，我有时认为关于英国是一个移民国家的说法往往被夸大了。如果说有什么不同的话，英国更多时候是
a nation of emigrants. It's been an exporter of people. And sometimes the story we tell ourselves about immigration to Britain in particular, misses out Irish migration, which was enormous. And that added another kind of piquancy to these questions that had been fundamental to British national identity from the kind of late 1500s onwards, when you had the arrival in huge numbers in the 19th century, not just in the famine period, although that massively expanded the numbers, but throughout the 19th century and into the early 20th century, huge numbers of Irish Catholics into particularly urban Britain. And there was such a thing as a backlash vote against them. It's a typical story. We don't like your religion. We don't like the fact you're coming here taking our jobs and reducing our wages. And we don't like the fact you're disloyal either. You cheered on the Boers during the Boer War. from based in Dublin would be like handing over the Falkland Islands to Argentina or Gibraltar to Spain. It would be that mind-blowing to people. What? This is how you're returning?
一个移民输出国。它一直是人口的输出者。有时我们对自己讲述的关于移民到英国的故事，特别是忽略了爱尔兰移民，那可是规模巨大的。这为这些问题增添了另一种尖锐性，这些问题从16世纪末开始就一直是英国民族认同的基础，当时在19世纪，不仅是在饥荒时期，尽管那极大地增加了人数，而且在整个19世纪和20世纪初，大量爱尔兰天主教徒涌入英国，特别是城市地区。而且确实存在针对他们的反弹投票。这是一个典型的故事。我们不喜欢你们的宗教。我们不喜欢你们来到这里抢走我们的工作并压低我们的工资。我们也不喜欢你们不忠诚的事实。你们在布尔战争期间为布尔人欢呼。从都柏林的立场来看，这就像把福克兰群岛交给阿根廷，或者把直布罗陀交给西班牙。这对人们来说是令人震惊的。什么？这就是你们回归的方式吗？
This is how you're repaying the loyalty of these sober, industrious people who just live in a place that just looks like Middlesbrough or Sheffield or wherever? This is outrageous. This is absolutely outrageous, and we won't stand for it. Those feelings still needed to be kindled though and exploited and fanned. And that's exactly what the Tory, the unionist parties that were widely known in that period do. And so isn't that the paradox that the people encouraging paramilitary displays in British cities and villages, the people who are seriously proposing that the army, rather than be sent to intervene, should potentially mutiny, that the people doing this are the avowed defenders of the constitution, the Tories, the Conservatives, the people
这就是你们回报这些清醒、勤劳的人们的方式吗？他们只是住在一个看起来像米德尔斯堡、谢菲尔德或其他什么地方的地方？这太令人愤慨了。这绝对是令人愤慨的，我们绝不会容忍。然而，这些情绪仍然需要被点燃、被利用、被煽动。而这正是当时广为人知的保守党和统一党所做的。那么，这难道不是一个悖论吗？那些在英国城市和乡村鼓励准军事组织展示的人，那些认真提议军队不应被派去干预，而应可能发生兵变的人，这些做这些事的人，竟然是宪法的公开捍卫者，是托利党人，是保守党人，是那些
who, by definition, oppose the kind of radical solutions. Tom, just to jump in for a second, I know what my answer to that would be, which is that, I mean, you see it in their speeches, Andrew Bonalor's speeches. He would say, through a terrible stroke of misfortune, power has been seized by a cynical group of revolutionaries, Asquith, Lloyd George. We are just taking up arms to defend. He would say we're defending the constitution, wouldn't he, Dan? Yeah dan yeah he would and he makes a famous speech speech at blenheim palace in late 1912 the gist of which is i can think of no length of resistance that ulster would go that they wouldn't either be justified in doing and that we won't support them in doing this is still at this ambiguous phase i mentioned earlier but even when the the ulster volunteer force is inaugurated in early 1913
按理说，他们反对那种激进的解决方案。汤姆，我插一句，我知道我的答案会是什么，那就是，我的意思是，你在他们的演讲中，在安德鲁·博纳·劳的演讲中就能看到。他会说，由于一场可怕的不幸，权力被一群愤世嫉俗的革命者——阿斯奎斯、劳合·乔治——夺取了。我们只是拿起武器进行自卫。他会说我们是在捍卫宪法，不是吗，丹？是的，丹，是的，他会这么说。他在1912年底在布伦海姆宫发表了一场著名的演讲，其大意是：我想不出阿尔斯特在抵抗方面会走多远，以至于他们这样做是不正当的，而且我们不会支持他们这样做。这仍然处于我之前提到的那个模糊阶段，但即使在1913年初阿尔斯特志愿军成立时
around the time by the way that carson, that Edward Carson introduces in Parliament an amendment to the Home Rule Bill to exclude all nine counties of the historic province of Ulster, that eventually becomes six counties after the First World War. Because the Ulster Unionists don't want their three extras that have lots of Catholics, do they? Because they think they won't be able to govern. Exactly. They want to make sure that the portion of Ulster has an inbuilt Protestant majority to safeguard their position. But that's a bit of a pill for Carson to swallow, of course, because he could see that this will leave the Southern Unionists, of which there are still quite a lot in places like Dublin, even Cork, Galway and other places. In urban Ireland, there are still quite a number of Unionists, but they don't have the numbers really, and they're Party to embrace a policy of revolution without parallel in modern British history. Do you think he's right about that? Completely. I think it's because the Tories in this period are completely boxed in.
顺便说一下，大约在那个时候，爱德华·卡森在议会提出了一项对《地方自治法案》的修正案，旨在将历史上的阿尔斯特省的全部九个郡排除在外，这在第一次世界大战后最终变成了六个郡。因为阿尔斯特统一党人不想把那三个有很多天主教徒的额外郡包括进来，对吧？因为他们认为他们将无法治理。没错。他们想确保阿尔斯特的那部分地区拥有内在的新教多数，以保障他们的地位。但这对卡森来说当然有点难以下咽，因为他能看出这将使南方统一党人处于孤立无援的境地，在都柏林、甚至科克、戈尔韦和其他地方，仍然有相当多的南方统一党人。在爱尔兰的城市里，仍然有相当多的统一党人，但他们的人数确实不够，而且他们是一个在现代英国历史上采取了史无前例的革命政策的政党。你认为他对此说得对吗？完全正确。我认为这是因为这一时期的保守党人完全陷入了困境。
Their support for the Constitution, if I was being cynical, is entirely provisional on it conforming to their understanding what the constitution should look like and not up for amendment via the democratic process and so they're they're quite willing brazenly willing to support the ulster volunteer force and there are really prominent conservative politicians if i can introduce one name here an absolutely massive lad called F.E. Smith. Dan, you've made me so happy that you've mentioned F.E. Smith. F.E. Smith. I mean, he is yet another barrister. And I always think this is bad news for a nation's polity when barristers are prominently involved in the political scene. But F.E. Smith, another extraordinarily wealthy, dazzling Oxford scholar, but he's a Liverpool Tory MP, and he understands what all this means. And Liverpool in this period is absolutely central to this story. It's where
如果我愤世嫉俗一点的话，他们对宪法的支持完全是有条件的，前提是它符合他们对宪法应该是什么样子的理解，而不是通过民主程序进行修正。所以他们非常愿意，厚颜无耻地愿意支持阿尔斯特志愿军。而且确实有非常显眼的保守党政客，如果我能在这里介绍一个名字的话，一个绝对重量级的人物，叫F.E.史密斯。丹，你提到F.E.史密斯让我太高兴了。F.E.史密斯。我的意思是，他又是另一位大律师。我一直认为，当大律师们显著参与政治舞台时，这对一个国家的政体来说是个坏消息。但F.E.史密斯，另一位极其富有、令人眼花缭乱的牛津学者，但他是一位利物浦的保守党议员，他明白这一切意味着什么。而利物浦在这一时期在这个故事中绝对处于核心地位。这就是
Carson goes after signing the covenant. He sails across the Irish Sea. The Liverpool Courier has this enormous headline, Liverpool's Sister of Belfast. And Liverpool is still this kind of sectarian cauldron. In 1910, the elections of 1910, nine out of the 11 Merseyside seats are held by unionists, one by a liberal, and the other one is held by an Irish nationalist, T.P. O'Connor, the only Irish nationalist MP outside of the island of Ireland. This is how unique this city is. And often think that liverpool's tradition is as england's most tory city which it was until right until the 1970s has been completely airbrushed out of that city's understanding yeah they don't go on about that now no no they can't the idea that a crowd of liverpool supporters would boo the national anthem as they were doing recently would be mind-boggling
卡森在签署盟约后去的地方。他横渡爱尔兰海。《利物浦信使报》有这样一个巨大的标题：“利物浦是贝尔法斯特的姐妹”。而利物浦仍然是这种宗派主义的温床。1910年，1910年的选举中，默西塞德郡的11个席位中有9个由统一党人把持，1个由自由党人把持，另一个由爱尔兰民族主义者T.P.奥康纳把持，这是爱尔兰岛以外唯一的爱尔兰民族主义议员。这就是这座城市有多么独特。我经常认为，利物浦作为英国最保守城市的传统——直到1970年代一直如此——已经完全从这座城市的认知中被抹去了。是的，他们现在不谈论这个了。不，不，他们不能。利物浦球迷在最近嘘国歌的想法简直令人难以置信。
even as recently as the 1950s. But Liverpool's political tradition was partly shaped by its economic base, which was largely landlordism in terms of dockside rather than productive industries, like Manchester was. The presence nearby of the landed interest through the earls of Derby, who were still very influential in British politics, but chiefly the growth of a native orange tradition in Liverpool, which was massive and largely prompted by a kind of backlash vote. But anyway, I mentioned F.E. Smith. He gets the nickname Galloper Smith because he acts as the sort of Carson's ADC, riding around on horseback at UVF parades and manoeuvres and so on in Northern Ireland
即使在1950年代也是如此。但利物浦的政治传统部分是由其经济基础塑造的，其经济基础在很大程度上是码头区的地主制，而不是像曼彻斯特那样的生产性工业。德比伯爵家族通过土地利益在附近的存在，他们在英国政治中仍然非常有影响力，但主要是利物浦本土奥兰治传统的增长，这种传统规模巨大，很大程度上是由一种反弹投票所推动的。但无论如何，我提到了F.E.史密斯。他得到了“飞奔的史密斯”这个绰号，因为他充当了卡森的副官，在北爱尔兰的UVF游行和演习中骑马四处奔走等等。
throughout 1913 and 14, quite brazenly supporting basically armed rebellion against the British government. Dan, I think you've sold F.E. Smith a tiny bit short by describing him as this incredibly charismatic and dashing barrister, because he's actually probably the greatest wit, isn't he? Or one of the two or three greatest wits. So he was Churchill's great hero. Tom, I'm going to read you some F.E. Smith quotes. Is this the wit and wisdom of F.E. Smith? Exactly, by Winston Churchill and his great contemporaries. So when F.E. Smith was a young barrister, he was up in front of a man called Judge Willis. And Judge Willis said to him,
在整个1913年和1914年，他厚颜无耻地支持基本上针对英国政府的武装叛乱。丹，我觉得你把F.E.史密斯描述成这位极其有魅力和潇洒的大律师，有点低估他了，因为他实际上可能是最伟大的机智人物，不是吗？或者两三个最伟大的机智人物之一。所以他是丘吉尔的大英雄。汤姆，我要给你读一些F.E.史密斯的语录。这是F.E.史密斯的机智和智慧吗？没错，出自温斯顿·丘吉尔和他伟大的同时代人之手。所以当F.E.史密斯还是一位年轻的大律师时，他在一位名叫威利斯法官的人面前。威利斯法官对他说，
Mr. Smith, have you ever heard of a saying by Bacon, the great Bacon, that youth and discretion are ill-witted companions? And F.E. Smith said, yes, I have. And have you, sir, ever heard of a saying by Bacon Bacon the great Bacon that a much-talking judge is like an ill-tuned cymbal and the judge at that said to him you are extremely offensive young man and Effie Smith said in open court as a matter of fact we both are but I'm trying to be and you can't help it but even better than that is he was talking to a high court judge who was presiding in a case of a man who'd been accused of sodomy. The high court judge said to F.E. Smith, could you tell me what do you think one ought to give a man who allows himself to be buggered?
“史密斯先生，你听说过伟大的培根说过的一句话吗，即青春和谨慎是糟糕的同伴？”F.E.史密斯说：“是的，我听说过。”“那么，先生，你听说过伟大的培根说过的一句话吗，即一个喋喋不休的法官就像一个音调不准的钹？”法官听了之后对他说：“你这个年轻人极其无礼。”F.E.史密斯在公开法庭上说：“事实上，我们两个都很无礼，但我是在努力做到这一点，而你却无法避免。”但比这更好的是，他当时正在和一位高等法院法官交谈，这位法官正在主持一个被指控鸡奸的男人的案件。高等法院法官对F.E.史密斯说：“你能告诉我，你认为一个人应该给一个允许自己被鸡奸的人什么吗？”
And F.E. Smith said, oh, 30 shillings or two pounds, whatever you happen to have on you. But that's the kind of joke that if Carson had been listening to it, he'd have got F.E. Smith sent to Reading Jail for 10 years or whatever. And F.E. Smith plays up to his – he was Churchill's great drinking buddy, even though Churchill's a liberal in this period. Smith's a Tory. He's making – F.E.'s making a speech somewhere, and he says – it's about the liberals' kind of welfare program. And he says something like, I see mr churchill has stolen the socialists clothes while they were bathing if they do bathe which i doubt so he's full of little quips like that but uh he's another charismatic figure i think i remember discussing with the great professor
F.E.史密斯说：“哦，30先令或两英镑，随便你身上有什么。”但那种笑话，如果卡森当时听到了，他会把F.E.史密斯送进雷丁监狱关上10年或者什么的。F.E.史密斯扮演着他的——他是丘吉尔伟大的酒友，尽管丘吉尔在这一时期是自由党人。史密斯是保守党人。他正在——F.E.在某个地方发表演讲，他说——这是关于自由党某种福利计划的。他说了一些类似的话：“我看到丘吉尔先生在社会主义者洗澡时偷了他们的衣服，如果他们真的洗澡的话，我对此表示怀疑。”所以他充满了这样的小俏皮话，但他——我认为他是另一个有魅力的人物。我记得曾与伟大的教授讨论过
roy foster once about uh doyen of ir Historians in many ways, about Edward Carson. And he said, Carson, you know, he had a certain sexual charisma that was well noted by not just female voters, I would imagine, but particularly female voters who were just kind of all of a quiver
罗伊·福斯特，在许多方面是爱尔兰历史学家的泰斗，关于爱德华·卡森。他说，卡森，你知道，他有一种被很好地注意到的性魅力，我想不仅是女性选民，特别是那些一见到他就心潮澎湃的女性选民。
whenever he appeared. And some people have seen a kind of a premonition of a sort of almost fascist vibe. I don't think that it's quite right, but I think there is something in the strong man, the mass rallies, the arc lights. The paramilitary is marching up and down.
每当他出现时。有些人看到了某种近乎法西斯氛围的预兆。我不认为这完全正确，但我认为在强人、群众集会、弧光灯中确实有一些东西。准军事组织在走来走去。
So, I mean, this is the age of the Boy Scout movement, I suppose, but it's also the age when there's an absolute fascination. I mean, Tom, we did that podcast about King Solomon's Mines, published, what, 20 years earlier? Obsession with manliness, with brotherhood, with people in tight trousers, riding up and down, promising civil wars. But specifically, this idea of Carson and F.E. Smith as kind of charismatic, almost sexually charged leaders, these are not the kind of people I imagine that Asquith, for instance, would particularly understand, would particularly have a handle on. So if Asquith doesn't understand
所以，我的意思是，我想这是童子军运动的时代，但这也是一个绝对着迷的时代。我的意思是，汤姆，我们做了那个关于《所罗门王的宝藏》的播客，出版于，什么，20年前？对男子气概、兄弟情谊、穿着紧身裤的人骑马走来走去、承诺内战的痴迷。但具体来说，这种将卡森和F.E.史密斯视为某种有魅力、几乎充满性张力的领袖的想法，这些不是我想象中阿斯奎斯等人会特别理解、特别能掌控的人。所以如果阿斯奎斯不理解
the emotions that are being stirred up in Ulster, the religious emotions, presumably also he's constitutionally incapable of understanding what the potential kind of power of people like Carson and Smith is as well. I mean, does he just simply not appreciate the scale of the crisis that he's building? I think he appreciates the crisis, but I just don't think he knows what to do about it. You see a bit of that in the First World War. There's a famous line, because you know, he was quite a laid back figure, to say the least, when he meets some society aristocratic lady and who says to him, this is about 1915
在阿尔斯特被煽动起来的情绪，宗教情绪，大概他也从宪法上无法理解像卡森和史密斯这样的人的潜在力量是什么。我的意思是，他难道只是简单地没有意识到他正在制造的危机的规模吗？我认为他意识到了危机，但我只是认为他不知道该怎么做。你在第一次世界大战中看到了一点。有一句名言，因为你知道，他是一个相当悠闲的人物，至少可以这么说，当他遇到一些社会贵族女士时，她对他说，这是大约1915年
or 16 he said mr askwith do you take an interest in the war you know because that's the dynamic leadership that britain needs so does he take an interest in ulster i think he basically askwith basically wishes it would all just go away you know he's not he's not the charismatic stump speaker that carson or smith or even bono law who's quite a quite a know, he's not the charismatic stump speaker that Carson or Smith or even Bonalor, who's quite a draw because he can fulminate and he's got that stern look about him as well. No contemporary political campaign gets the numbers out on the streets like Carson's campaign, which he quickly realizes it's no good just speaking to demonstrations in Belfast. He needs to go and shift public opinion in Britain.
或16年，她说：“阿斯奎斯先生，你对战争感兴趣吗？”你知道，因为那是英国需要的充满活力的领导力。那么他对阿尔斯特感兴趣吗？我想他基本上——阿斯奎斯基本上希望这一切都能消失。你知道，他不是卡森或史密斯，甚至不是博纳·劳那样的魅力型演说家，博纳·劳相当——你知道，他不是卡森或史密斯那样的魅力型演说家，甚至不是博纳·劳，他相当——他很有吸引力，因为他能大声疾呼，而且他看起来也很严厉。没有当代政治运动能像卡森的运动那样把人数带到街上，他很快意识到仅仅在贝尔法斯特的示威活动中演讲是不够的。他需要去改变英国的公众舆论。
And that's what he spends his time doing throughout 1913 and the first half of 1914. But aren't there two other things though? One, the liberals are trapped. They rely on the Irish parliamentary party, the Irish nationalists of John Redmond, to whom they've promised home rule. So they can't welch out of it because then they're sunk.
这就是他在整个1913年和1914年上半年所做的事情。但难道没有另外两件事吗？第一，自由党人被困住了。他们依赖约翰·雷德蒙的爱尔兰议会党，即爱尔兰民族主义者，他们向这些人承诺了地方自治。所以他们不能食言，因为那样他们就完了。
Then they lose their majority. That's number one. But number two, because of this, what seems like a very arcane procedural thing, which is the Parliament Act, which means the House of Lords can't scrap your legislation. They can delay it for two years, can't they? You have to introduce it three times. Because of that, they're stuck on this, you know, what's the expression? It's not a treadmill.
然后他们就会失去多数席位。这是第一点。但第二点，因为这个看起来非常晦涩的程序性问题，即《议会法案》，这意味着上议院不能废除你们的立法。他们可以推迟两年，对吧？你必须引入三次。因为这个，他们被困在这个，你知道，是什么表达？这不是跑步机。
It's one of those things that- Hamster wheel. Hamster wheel. Exactly. They're in a hamster wheel. And it's very Brexit, isn't it? Yeah, it is very Brexit. They're stuck.
这是那种——仓鼠轮。仓鼠轮。没错。他们在一个仓鼠轮里。这非常像英国脱欧，不是吗？是的，这非常像英国脱欧。他们被困住了。
The sense of a ticking clock. They're stuck, but it's a three-year ticking clock, right? 1912, 1913, 1914. And that means that Carson has the best part of two to three years to go around the country whipping people up, but also presumably to recruit his paramilitaries and to get guns. But Dan, I mean, a thing that a government does when faced by an insurgent paramilitary force is to send the police or failing that, the army in, to suppress them. So why don't they do that? Well, I think firstly, that would be quite a big step. And the Liberal government in this
滴答作响的时钟的感觉。他们被困住了，但这是一个三年的滴答作响的时钟，对吧？1912年，1913年，1914年。这意味着卡森有两到三年的大部分时间可以去全国各地煽动人们，但也大概可以招募他的准军事人员并获得枪支。但丹，我的意思是，政府在面对叛乱的准军事力量时所做的一件事是派遣警察，或者如果失败了，就派遣军队去镇压他们。那么他们为什么不这样做呢？嗯，我认为首先，那将是一个相当大的步骤。而自由党政府在这一
period are hoping that the Irish Home Rule can be enacted peacefully. They'd rather not have any confrontations because, of course, this is a period where there are troops on the streets more often than more or less any other time in the 20th century. If you read George Dangerfield's famous book, The Strange Death of Liberal England, particularly confrontations over trade union disputes in 1911, it's quite a febrile atmosphere. And the last thing you want is, you know, having to deal with, you know, striking railways in Liverpool or wherever and then having to send troops to Northern Ireland. But of course, as it will play out when we get to 1914, the loyalty of the army, particularly its Anglo-Irish officer caste, are absolutely not on board with the idea of enforcing home rule on basically their family and friends in the north of Ireland, or in fact, in Dublin as well, of course, given that many of those landed families were based in the south of Ireland too.
时期希望爱尔兰地方自治能够和平实施。他们宁愿没有任何对抗，因为当然，这是一个在20世纪军队出现在街头比任何其他时间都多的时期。如果你读乔治·丹格菲尔德那本著名的书《自由主义英国的奇异死亡》，特别是1911年关于工会纠纷的对抗，那是一种相当狂热的氛围。而你最不想做的就是，你知道，不得不处理，你知道，利物浦或其他地方的铁路罢工，然后不得不派遣军队去北爱尔兰。但当然，正如当我们进入1914年时将会发生的那样，军队的忠诚，特别是其英裔爱尔兰军官阶层，绝对不赞成在北爱尔兰的家人和朋友身上强制执行地方自治的想法，或者事实上，在都柏林也是如此，当然，考虑到许多那些土地所有者家庭也居住在爱尔兰南部。
So they couldn't really rely on the army. And this is demonstrated by what's called the Curragh Incident, the Curragh Mutiny. The Curragh Mutiny, yeah. Yeah. So this is how this whole story plays out. The UVF forms in 1913. It very rapidly professionalizes itself. It brings in a retired Indian army general to command it. It's drilling regularly and so on, but it's short of arms. So it manages through this kind of John Buchan-esque gunrunning episode where a ship sails from, I think it's Denmark,
所以他们真的无法依赖军队。这一点通过所谓的“库拉事件”，即“库拉兵变”得到了证明。库拉兵变，是的。是的。所以这就是整个故事的发展方式。UVF在1913年成立。它非常迅速地实现了专业化。它请来了一位退休的印度陆军将军来指挥它。它经常进行演习等等，但它缺乏武器。所以它通过这种约翰·巴肯式的走私枪支事件设法做到了，一艘船从，我想是丹麦，
and eventually arrives at Laan on the northern Irish coast, importing 24,000 rifles, which they purchased from Germany. The Ulster Unionists had bought outright, but had to basically spuggle into the country. This is a huge deal at the time. And when the army get wind of this at the Curragh camp, which is the main British army base just outside Dublin, many of them make their feelings known to their commanding officer to say, we won't, we'd rather resign our commissions than be forced to coerce the unionists in the North into accepting Irish Home Rule. What happens then? The government panic, the army, some of the more kind of loyal, if you want to put it that way, army top brass try and rein these officers in,
最终抵达北爱尔兰海岸的拉恩，进口了24,000支步枪，这些步枪是从德国购买的。阿尔斯特统一党人直接购买了这些步枪，但基本上不得不走私进该国。这在当时是一件大事。当军队在库拉营地（这是都柏林郊外主要的英国陆军基地）得到消息时，他们中的许多人向他们的指挥官表达了他们的感受，说：“我们不会，我们宁愿辞去军职，也不愿被迫强迫北方的统一党人接受爱尔兰地方自治。”然后发生了什么？政府恐慌了，军队，一些比较忠诚的（如果你想这么说的话）军队高层试图约束这些军官，
but they're adamant. Many of them are Anglo-Irish, as I mentioned. And then there's an enormous demonstration in Hyde Park in London with about a quarter of a million people who turn out to hear Edward Carson speak in defence of the Curragh mutineers, as they're called. The popular opinion is, well, they're doing exactly the right thing. This is completely unjust to try and impose this on Northern Ireland. When you say the popular opinion, Dan, this is an age before opinion polls. Do we actually have a sense of what the British, maybe, I don't know, from by-elections or whatever, of what the British public, which way they would have, the majority or plurality would have sided? Well, this is basically the question that I try to explore in my book on this topic, which was,
但他们很坚定。他们中的许多人是英裔爱尔兰人，正如我提到的。然后伦敦海德公园举行了一场巨大的示威活动，大约有25万人出来听爱尔兰卡森为所谓的“库拉兵变者”辩护。大众的观点是，好吧，他们做得完全正确。试图强加给北爱尔兰是完全不公正的。当你提到大众观点时，丹，这是一个在民意调查之前的时代。我们真的知道英国公众，也许，我不知道，从补选或其他什么，英国公众，他们中的多数或多数会站在哪一边吗？嗯，这基本上是我试图在我的关于这个主题的书中探讨的问题，那就是，
there aren't opinion polls. The evidence from ordinary voters is usually sketchy. You usually only ever get high political accounts of this period, which I thought was a major gap in the historiography. So you try and discover how people were feeling. And one of the ways you can look at it is the huge demonstrations. And Carson speaks everywhere in Britain. He speaks in Inverness, in Plymouth, in Norwich, in Mountain Ash, in the Ronda Valley, in Birmingham, frequently in Liverpool and Glasgow as you might expect but in Walls End, in Durham, at the Hearn Hill, Velodrome Tom not far from Holland Towers. He speaks to a mass demonstration in 1914. So there's usually huge turnout for these events. They're often highly
没有民意调查。来自普通选民的证据通常很粗略。你通常只能得到这一时期的高层政治叙述，我认为这是史学上的一个重大空白。所以你试图发现人们的感觉。你可以观察它的方式之一是巨大的示威活动。卡森在英国各地演讲。他在因弗内斯、普利茅斯、诺里奇、山灰镇、朗达谷、伯明翰演讲，正如你所预料的那样，经常在利物浦和格拉斯哥演讲，但在沃尔森德、达勒姆、赫恩山、自行车馆，汤姆，离荷兰塔不远。他在1914年向一场大规模示威活动发表了演讲。所以这些活动通常有巨大的参与人数。它们通常高度
stylized. Have you ever watched the Mitchell and Kenyon archive of kind of Edwardian newsreels? And you see how often processions were a big deal for the Edwardians and various different guys as religious, trade unions, whatever. The usual deal would be there'd be a procession through the town, bit like an Orange March almost, similar sort of thing. Or Carson's carriage would be unhorsed and loyal supporters would pull him through the town. So he gets huge numbers out onto the street. And at the same time, the Liberal government are losing by-elections left, right and centre to unionists who are campaigning on this platform. So Dan, the army has, elements of the army seem to mutinied. There are all these processions. There are people drilling. So there's not just the volunteers in Ulster. There's been a rival group of Irish volunteers
风格化。你看过米切尔和凯尼恩档案馆的爱德华时代新闻片吗？你看到游行对爱德华时代的人来说是多么重要，各种各样的家伙，宗教的、工会的，无论什么。通常的做法是，在镇上进行游行，有点像奥兰治游行，类似的事情。或者卡森的马车会被卸下马，忠诚的支持者会拉着他穿过城镇。所以他让大量的人走上街头。与此同时，自由党政府在补选中左、右、中都输给了在这个平台上竞选的统一党人。所以丹，军队有，军队的某些部分似乎发生了兵变。有所有这些游行。有人在演习。所以不仅仅是阿尔斯特的志愿者。还有一个竞争对手，爱尔兰志愿者
that has been formed, I think, in 1913. There's also talk of people recruiting in Britain, people signing covenants in Britain. And the question is, what's George? I said, George V, very much a friend of the rest is history, top king, what's he doing? I mean, he must be thinking, geez, my United Kingdom is, you know, heading for the knacker's yard. The king is massively spooked by this. And of course, he's had a tough early period of his reign because he was going to be forced to flood the House of Lords with liberal peers, of course,
已经在1913年成立了。还有关于人们在英国招募、人们在英国签署盟约的讨论。问题是，乔治在做什么？我说，乔治五世，非常是历史的朋友，顶级国王，他在做什么？我的意思是，他一定在想，天哪，我的联合王国正在，你知道，走向废品站。国王对此感到非常惊恐。当然，他统治的早期阶段很艰难，因为他将被迫用自由党贵族充斥上议院，当然，
at the height of the people's budget debate, which I think you've touched on already. But George V intervenes in politics. He calls the Buckingham Palace Conference in July 1914 to try and get the key players around the table to try and thrash out some sort of compromise. But of course, the Irish nationalists are not willing to compromise, and they still see the island of Ireland as a single political unit, and they're not prepared. But Dan, this is happening in July 1914, and they're having to have a conference to discuss what to do about Ireland. But I thought the Home Rule Bill has already passed, hasn't it? So why are they still discussing it? Tom, I don't want to terrify the listeners, but we've actually given them a very, very simplified version of the story.
在人民预算辩论的高潮时期，我想你已经提到过了。但乔治五世干预了政治。他在1914年7月召开了白金汉宫会议，试图让关键参与者围坐在桌旁，试图商讨出某种妥协。但当然，爱尔兰民族主义者不愿意妥协，他们仍然将爱尔兰岛视为一个单一的政治单位，他们没有准备好。但丹，这发生在1914年7月，他们不得不召开会议讨论如何处理爱尔兰问题。但我以为《地方自治法案》已经通过了，不是吗？所以为什么他们还在讨论它？汤姆，我不想吓唬听众，但我们实际上给了他们一个非常、非常简化的故事版本。
It's even more complex. Well, because the bill had passed in May 1914. I think that's right, isn't it, Dan? The bill had passed in May, but even at that point, the Asquith government are still dithering about what to do with it. They are talking about excluding part of Ulster. But the question now is, are they going to exclude a bit of it? Are they going to exclude the whole province? Are they going to exclude nine counties, six, maybe even three counties? And does that mean they're going to sell out in Carson's view or the unionists? I mean, he's still holding out for no home rule at all. Okay, but what does the Irish Parliamentary Party think about this? Because they've been promised home rule, the bill has passed, and it's still not being instituted. So what's their take
它甚至更复杂。嗯，因为该法案在1914年5月通过了。我想那是对的，不是吗，丹？该法案在5月通过了，但即使在那时，阿斯奎斯政府仍然在犹豫该怎么处理它。他们正在谈论排除阿尔斯特的一部分。但现在的问题是，他们要排除它的一小部分吗？他们要排除整个省吗？他们要排除九个郡、六个，甚至可能是三个郡吗？这是否意味着他们要出卖卡森眼中的利益，或者统一党人的利益？我的意思是，他仍然坚持完全不要地方自治。好吧，但爱尔兰议会党对此怎么看？因为他们被承诺了地方自治，法案已经通过了，但它仍然没有被实施。所以他们的看法是什么
on this? basis. And he's not prepared to concede ground to the Ulster Unionists, no matter how much they're recruiting to the UVF. Maybe there's a sense that John Redmond underestimates the vehemence of their opposition. You kind of expect that once it's passed through Parliament, then it will happen. The Liberal government will ensure it will happen. But it just doesn't, though, because it stands on a knife edge. There's kind of real brinkmanship in this period about how is this going to play out? Because as Dominic touched on before, not only have we had the Ulster Covenant, we've had the British Covenant as well.
关于这一点？基础。而且他没有准备好向阿尔斯特统一党人让步，无论他们招募了多少人进入UVF。也许有一种感觉，约翰·雷德蒙低估了他们反对的激烈程度。你有点期望一旦它通过议会，那么它就会发生。自由党政府将确保它发生。但它就是没有发生，因为它处于刀刃上。在这一时期，关于这将如何发展，有一种真正的边缘政策？因为正如多米尼克之前提到的，我们不仅有了《阿尔斯特盟约》，我们也有了《英国盟约》。
And it's claimed in some circles that 2 million people signed the British Covenant in Britain. This is outside of Ireland. People are openly joining UVF-style groups in Glasgow and London and Liverpool and are willing to go and defend Ulster in the event of violence. Is it fair to say that by July 1914, the government is faced with large numbers of people in Ulster and across Britain who are
在某些圈子里声称，有200万人签署了《英国盟约》。这是在爱尔兰之外。人们公开加入格拉斯哥、伦敦和利物浦的UVF风格团体，并愿意在发生暴力事件时去保卫阿尔斯特。公平地说，到1914年7月，政府面临着阿尔斯特和英国各地的大量人口，他们
prepared to resort to violence in defence certainly certainly of Ulster, staying British, not being subjected to home rule as they would see it. And at the same time, presumably, this is radicalising nationalist opinion in Catholic Ireland too. Completely. So just as the Ulster volunteers had illegally smuggled guns into the north of Ireland, in many respects, the Ulster volunteers are sort of admired by the Irish volunteers. They kind of admire their pluck and the action they're taking. And they likewise import guns via the yacht that belongs to the novelist Erskine Childers, who'd written that novel, The Riddle of the Sands in 1903. Fascinating character. But they import arms via Hoth, which is a town outside dublin and this leads to a bit of a
准备在保卫阿尔斯特的问题上诉诸暴力，当然，保持英国身份，不被他们所认为的地方自治所束缚。与此同时，大概这也激化了天主教爱尔兰的民族主义情绪。完全正确。所以正如阿尔斯特志愿者非法将枪支走私到爱尔兰北部一样，在许多方面，阿尔斯特志愿者在某种程度上受到爱尔兰志愿者的钦佩。他们有点钦佩他们的勇气和他们正在采取的行动。他们同样通过属于小说家厄斯金·柴尔德斯的游艇进口枪支，他曾在1903年写过那本小说《沙洲之谜》。迷人的人物。但他们通过霍斯进口武器，这是一个都柏林郊外的城镇，这导致了一点
confrontation afterwards in the city of dublin between british troops and sympathizers with the gunrunners as they're seen and some some irish people are killed so this adds to the sense of kind of this febrile stuff that's going on in the summer of 1914 but also the one-sidedness right that the british troops refused to do anything against the Unionist gunrunners. And indeed, there was the Curragh Mutiny, but they've opened fire on a crowd of Irish Catholic supporters of the Irish volunteer gunrunners. So it's as though they're party-free. Well, they are party-free, I suppose. Completely. And the injustice seems obvious to people. And this adds to the sense of, well, neither side want to back down.
随后的对抗，在都柏林市，英国军队和走私枪支者的同情者之间，正如他们所看到的那样，一些爱尔兰人被杀。所以这增加了1914年夏天正在发生的这种狂热事物的感官。但也有一边倒，对吧？英国军队拒绝采取任何行动反对统一党走私枪支者。事实上，确实发生了库拉兵变，但他们向一群支持爱尔兰志愿者走私枪支者的爱尔兰天主教支持者开火了。所以就好像他们是无党的。嗯，我想他们是无党的。完全正确。而且这种不公正对人们来说似乎很明显。这增加了那种感觉，好吧，双方都不想退缩。
And this is where Britain is poised in the summer months of 1914. All attention is on Ireland. There's an editorial written in the Liverpool Courier that says, you know, if a spark happens in Belfast, say, the first blood spilled in Ulster would raise a storm in the large towns of England and Scotland. The problem of the working classes of Liverpool, Glasgow, Barrow, Manchester and Newcastle would be difficult to handle and would be even worse than in Belfast. Now, that might be an exaggeration because the Liverpool Courier was a Tory paper, but still, there's no sense of a resolution to this problem, and then something happens. But Dan, before the thing happens, so in other words, D'Arcy Franz Ferdinand is assassinated on the 28th of June. Austria declares war on Serbia on the 28th of July. That crisis could have played out differently. The Austrians could not have made the decision they did or whatever. Had that not happened, I mean, I know Tom and I
这就是1914年夏天英国所处的位置。所有的注意力都集中在爱尔兰。在《利物浦信使报》上写的一篇社论说，你知道，如果贝尔法斯特发生火花，比如说，在阿尔斯特流下的第一滴血会在英格兰和苏格兰的大城镇引发一场风暴。利物浦、格拉斯哥、巴罗、曼彻斯特和纽卡斯尔工人阶级的问题将难以处理，甚至会比贝尔法斯特更糟。现在，这可能是一种夸张，因为《利物浦信使报》是一份保守党报纸，但仍然，没有解决这个问题的感觉，然后发生了一些事情。但丹，在事情发生之前，换句话说，弗朗茨·斐迪南大公在6月28日被暗杀。奥地利在7月28日对塞尔维亚宣战。那场危机本可以有不同的发展。奥地利人本可以不做出他们所做的决定，或者什么的。如果那没有发生，我的意思是，我知道汤姆和我
are always rubbishing what ifs. It's one of our specialities, but had that not happened, do you think civil war would have happened before the end of the year? I think if violence had broken out in Ireland, that would have affected the whole of the United Kingdom in 1914. But it's hard to see, I guess, how the violence might have happened, given that, in effect, we're in this stalemate position in 1914. The bill had passed but there was no real prospect of enforcing an ulster given the position of the army the relative weakness of the liberal government the fact that neither neither the irish nationalists or the ulster unionists or the british tory party torian unionist party wanted to give any ground
总是抨击“如果”。这是我们的特长之一，但如果那没有发生，你认为内战会在年底前发生吗？我认为如果爱尔兰爆发了暴力事件，那将影响1914年的整个联合王国。但很难看出，我想，暴力是如何发生的，考虑到，实际上，我们在1914年处于这种僵局。法案已经通过了，但考虑到军队的立场、自由党政府的相对软弱、爱尔兰民族主义者、阿尔斯特统一党人或英国托利党和统一党都不想让步的事实，在阿尔斯特强制执行并没有真正的希望
here so the kind of trenches were dug as it were It's hard to see how this could have been resolved peacefully. But we were awaiting a spark. So Dan, the Irish historian Michael Laffan says of this period that it is the greatest crisis to confront a British government since the civil wars of the 17th century. So presumably you would agree with that. I do agree. And as I said at the start of this discussion, this is the last time that religion really seriously mattered. But it's also the last time that Ireland really mattered in British politics. Because I think that even at the height of the troubles, what was happening in Northern Ireland didn't really affect the outcome of British general elections. No, not at all. It was a serious issue, but it didn't really change how people voted, I wouldn't say. Maybe it contributed to people rewarding the Labour government after the Good Friday Agreement or whatever,
这里，所以战壕被挖好了，可以说。很难看出这怎么能和平解决。但我们在等待火花。所以丹，爱尔兰历史学家迈克尔·拉凡说，这一时期是自17世纪内战以来英国政府面临的最大危机。所以大概你会同意这一点。我同意。正如我在这次讨论开始时所说，这是宗教真正重要、真正严重的最后一次。但这也是爱尔兰在英国政治中真正重要的最后一次。因为我认为即使在动乱的高潮时期，北爱尔兰发生的事情并没有真正影响英国大选的结果。不，一点也不。这是一个严重的问题，但我不会说它真的改变了人们的投票方式。也许它促成了人们在《贝尔法斯特协议》之后奖励工党政府，或者什么的，
but it never really mattered again, arguably until 2014 in the Scottish independence referendum. The union had been a dead issue for a long time. But it goes back to my original point that the First World War changed everything. Everything was changed, changed utterly. You know, as soon as war was declared, the British government introduces what's called a suspensory act, which is to say we won't enact the Home Rule for Ireland until at least one year after the cessation of hostilities. They had no idea how long the war was going to end. So the Irish issue is effectively parked.
但它再也没有真正重要过，可以说直到2014年的苏格兰独立公投。联合问题已经是一个死问题很长一段时间了。但这回到了我最初的观点，即第一次世界大战改变了一切。一切都改变了，彻底改变了。你知道，战争一宣布，英国政府就引入了所谓的《中止法案》，也就是说，我们至少在敌对行动停止一年后才会在爱尔兰实施地方自治。他们根本不知道战争会持续多久。所以爱尔兰问题实际上被搁置了。
But I think there are bigger issues that happen in the course of the First World War. You know, the extension of the franchise in 1918, the exhaustion of the First World War. No one wants to go back to what Churchill called the dreary steeples of Fermanagh and Tyrone. Irish issues were the last thing on Britain's mind, even in the teeth of an Irish war of independence and then civil war. People just weren't as bothered as they once were. And I've got this hunch that for a lot of people, the social mixing in the trenches of the First World War was another decisive factor because people didn't used to mix across religious lines.
但我认为在第一次世界大战期间发生了更大的问题。你知道，1918年选举权的扩大，第一次世界大战的疲惫。没有人想回到丘吉尔所说的“弗马纳和蒂龙阴沉的尖塔”。爱尔兰问题是英国人脑海中最后考虑的事情，即使在爱尔兰独立战争和随后的内战期间也是如此。人们只是不像以前那样在意了。我有一种预感，对很多人来说，第一次世界大战战壕中的社会融合是另一个决定性因素，因为人们过去不跨越宗教界限进行交流。
People have been taught for centuries that Catholics were this disloyal fifth column in Britain. And then they served alongside them in the trenches and they saw how brave they were. They saw how gallant their Irish Roman Catholic chaplains were. And they went, do you know what? They're actually all right, this lot. It was all nonsense what we were told. Isn't there a more cynical explanation though? I mean, in Ronan Fanning's book that we've mentioned a few times, Fatal Path, one of the reasons he says in his preface that he wrote that book was because he wants to show, to some degree, that violence worked. That violence, radicalisation won. That it got results. He doesn't necessarily like it, but that's how he sees it.
几个世纪以来，人们一直被教导天主教徒是英国不忠诚的第五纵队。然后他们在战壕里与他们并肩作战，他们看到了他们是多么勇敢。他们看到了他们的爱尔兰罗马天主教随军牧师是多么英勇。他们说，你知道吗？他们实际上还不错，这一群人。我们被告知的一切都是胡说八道。难道没有更愤世嫉俗的解释吗？我的意思是，在罗南·范宁的书《致命路径》中，我们提到过几次，他在序言中说他写那本书的原因之一是因为他想在某种程度上表明，暴力是有效的。暴力、激进化赢了。它取得了结果。他未必喜欢它，但这就是他看待它的方式。
Couldn't you say that the reason the issue fades for people in Britain is that the Ulster Unionists won. They got what they wanted by arming, by marching, by making the great hullabaloo with their Tory allies. They were excluded from home rule. They eventually get their own parliament. I mean, they didn't necessarily want their own parliament to begin with, but they get their own parliament. They get the six-county state that they wanted, but they get their way. As in fact, of course, to the Catholic Irish nationalists, both sides get their way as in fact of course to the catholic irish nationalists both sides get their way and so that's why it's settled some degree isn't it i mean there are people who lose out obviously which are the kind of minorities either
难道你不能说，英国人对这个问题不再关注的原因是阿尔斯特统一党人赢了。他们通过武装、游行、与他们的托利党盟友制造巨大的喧嚣得到了他们想要的。他们被排除在地方自治之外。他们最终得到了自己的议会。我的意思是，他们起初未必想要自己的议会，但他们得到了自己的议会。他们得到了他们想要的六郡国家，但他们如愿以偿了。事实上，当然，对于天主教爱尔兰民族主义者来说，双方都如愿以偿了，事实上，当然，对于天主教爱尔兰民族主义者来说，双方都如愿以偿了，所以这就是为什么它在某种程度上解决了，不是吗？我的意思是，显然有输家，也就是边界两边的少数群体，特别是在北方，但那两个多数群体，如果你愿意的话，都赢了，所以英国的人们说，太好了，他们赢了，让他们继续吧，你不觉得吗？是的，我认为那是对的，我对罗南·范宁关于那个问题的看法有很多同情。甚至卡森实际上回顾了那个时期，并在1920年代初写道，我们只是政治游戏中的一颗棋子。我们被利用了，我们的运动被托利党利用来重新掌权。我不完全相信，我更倾向于你对这个问题的看法和罗南·范宁的看法，即对许多英国人来说，这似乎是一个明智的解决方案。它不理想。它解决了。我们不会对北爱尔兰的新教徒强加任何东西，正如它后来所变成的那样。所以让我们就这样吧。但丹，你是否也认为，英国人之所以不记得这一点，是因为
side of the border especially in the north but those two majorities if you like both win and so people in britain say great they've won let them crack on don't you think yeah i think that's right and i've got a lot of sympathy for Ronan Fanning's view on that question. Even Carson actually looks back on that period and writes in the early 1920s to say we were just a pawn in a political game. We were used, our campaign was used by the Tories to get back in power. I don't quite believe, I align more with your take on this and Ronan Fanning's take that to a lot of British people it was, this seems like a sensible solution. It's not ideal. It's settled. We're not going to impose anything on the Protestants of Northern Ireland as it became. So let's just leave it. But do you think also, Dan, that the reason that people in Britain don't remember this is because
他们选择不去记住它？因为实际上它威胁到了英国政治一直以来是和平的、宪法的、基于法律的观念。我们不想记住暴力在巨大的宪法问题上实际上是多么有效。我的意思是，一个最终导致联合王国被撕裂的问题。是的，我认为这是一个非常好的观点。我认为整个这一时期，这就是为什么我在开始时提到，人们对爱德华时代作为这个印度之夏的稍微带有深褐色调的看法，正如我提到的，是完全错误的。我不知道那来自哪里。
they have chosen not to remember it? because actually it threatens the idea of British politics as always having been Pacific, constitutional, law-based. We don't want to remember how effective violence actually was in an immense constitutional issue. I mean, one that ends up ripping a chunk of the United Kingdom away. Yes, I think that's a really good point. I think that this whole period, that's why I mentioned at the start that people's slightly sepia-tinged view of the Edwardian period as this Indian summer, as I mentioned, is completely false. And I don't know where that comes from.
也许这是一个故意的行为，因为人们可以记得在英国，如果不是在爱尔兰本身，它可能变得多么狂热，多么具有潜在的暴力性。所以这个故事几十年来基本上被埋没了。但肯定对那两件事的回答是，它回到了你在最开始说的那件事，丹，关于大战改变了一切。大战在民族想象中掩盖了这一点。当然，人们总是会记得索姆河、帕斯尚尔、伊普尔，而不是关于《地方自治法案》的宪法争论，然后是很多并没有真正发生的准军事暴力。所以这是一个更大的故事。
Maybe it was a deliberate thing because people could remember how febrile, how potentially violent it could have easily become in Britain, if not in Ireland itself. And so this story has been largely buried for decades. But surely the answer to that is, to both of those things, is it goes back to the thing you said right at the beginning, Dan, about the Great War changing everything. The Great War eclipses this in the national imagination. Of course, people are always going to remember the Somme, Pashtun Dale, Ypres, rather than constitutional wranglings about the Home Rule Act, and then a lot of paramilitary violence that kind of doesn't quite happen. So it's a bigger story.
但同时，也是因为大战，人们构建了这种关于战前生活是什么样子的幻想形象，你不觉得吗？因为他们在梦想一个失去的黄金时代，你知道，在这些成千上万的人被杀之前。从未有过如此纯真。是的，我完全同意。事实上，还有另一个潜在的角度，那就是在第一次世界大战之前，在这个故事中如此重要的地方，如果我以利物浦为例，它们在全国对话中再也没有那么突出了。你知道，领先的政治家，当然是1960年代的哈罗德·威尔逊，像利物浦、北方、苏格兰这样的城市，在全国对话中再也没有像1914年之前那样重要了。所以利物浦和格拉斯哥发生暴力的前景是一个非常
But also, it's because of the Great War that people construct this fantasy image of what life was like before the war, don't you think? Because they're dreaming of a lost golden age, you know, before this, you know, these hundreds of thousands of people were killed. Never such innocence. Yeah, I completely agree. And actually, there's a potentially other angle as well, which was the places that were so important in that story before the First World War, if I take Liverpool, for example, they were never as prominent again in the national conversation. You know, leading politicians, Harold Wilson, of course, in the 1960s, cities like Liverpool, the North, Scotland, were never as quite as important as they once were in the national conversation as they were before 1914. So the prospect of violence in Liverpool and Glasgow is a very
但这也是因为大战，人们才构建了战前生活是什么样子的幻想形象，你不觉得吗？因为他们梦想着一个失去的黄金时代，你知道，在成千上万的人被杀之前。从未有过如此纯真。是的，我完全同意。实际上，可能还有另一个角度，那就是在第一次世界大战之前在那个故事中非常重要的地方，如果我以利物浦为例，它们在全国对话中再也没有那么突出了。你知道，像哈罗德·威尔逊这样的主要政治家，当然是在20世纪60年代，像利物浦、北部、苏格兰这样的城市，在全国对话中再也没有像1914年之前那样重要了。所以利物浦和格拉斯哥发生暴力的前景是非常
different proposition in 1914 as it would have been in the 1980s. Right. So the United Kingdom in 1914 does not erupt into violence, but we have a sense that in some way paramilitaries in Ulster have kind of won. Home rule has not been given to Ireland. And of course, a knock-on effect of that is that it influences paramilitaries in nationalist Ireland to play the card of violence. And that, Dominic, is really the subject of our next and final episode in this, because two years after the beginning of the war, violence comes to the streets of Dublin. It does indeed in the East Rising. So for that episode, which of course you can listen to
与20世纪80年代的情况截然不同。没错。因此，1914年的英国并没有爆发暴力冲突，但我们感觉到，阿尔斯特地区的准军事组织在某种程度上算是赢了。爱尔兰并没有获得自治权。当然，其连锁反应是，它影响了爱尔兰民族主义者的准军事组织，使他们打出了暴力这张牌。多米尼克，这正是我们本系列下一集，也就是最后一集的主题，因为战争开始两年后，暴力事件就出现在了都柏林的街头。确实，在复活节起义中。所以对于那一集，你当然可以收听
if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club. So if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, you can listen to that right now. But if not, you'll have to wait until Thursday because that is when we will be returning Dan to his box and we will be taking out again, but we will be returning, won't we, to returning won't we to the gpo in dublin tom taking wing back to dublin we'll be back in dublin at the gpo at the epicenter of the irish
如果你是“历史余韵”俱乐部的会员。所以，如果你是“历史余韵”俱乐部的会员，你现在就可以收听了。但如果不是，你就得等到周四，因为那时我们将把丹送回他的盒子里，然后再把他拿出来，但我们会回到都柏林的邮政总局，汤姆，我们会回到都柏林，回到都柏林邮政总局，回到爱尔兰革命的中心
revolution in 1916 for the easter rising with professor paul rouse but we can talk about paul rouse next time because dan that was somebody once sometimes says that people on this podcast are responsible for these great tour de force. You ever heard anybody say that, Dan? Once or twice, I think. Once or twice. So at this time, instead of him saying it, I will say it. That was an absolutely splendid tour de force.
1916年的复活节起义，届时会有保罗·劳斯教授参加。但我们可以下次再谈保罗·劳斯，因为丹，有人曾经说过，这个播客上的人要为这些伟大的杰作负责。你听过有人这么说吗，丹？我想有一两次吧。一两次。所以这一次，我不让他说，我来说。那绝对是一场精彩绝伦的杰作。
So your book, your PhD, which I heartily, it's a tremendous page turner. It's called Popular Opposition to Irish Home Rule in Edwardian Britain. It's still available in all good bookshops, isn't it, Dan, from Liverpool University Press? Maybe not WH Smith's, but... No, it's available at a fairly discounted price of £23.99, I'm told. That's insane value. Insane value.
所以你的书，你的博士论文，我衷心地推荐，这是一本非常引人入胜的书。书名叫《爱德华时代英国民众对爱尔兰自治的反对》。它在所有好的书店里仍然有售，对吧，丹，利物浦大学出版社出版的？也许WH Smith书店没有，但是……不，我听说它以23.99英镑的相当优惠的价格出售。这简直太划算了。太划算了。
Rush out and buy it now. That's actually, that is actually remarkably good value for a PhD thesis. That's not bad. But of course, the other book of Dan's that you can absolutely get very readily is The Northumbrians on a very different topic, but absolutely wonderful, wonderful book. So Dan, thank you so much. Thank you everyone for listening. And we will be back on Thursday with the Easter Rising.
快去买吧。说实话，作为一本博士论文，这确实非常超值。还不错。当然，丹的另一本书你绝对可以很容易买到，那就是《诺森布里亚人》，虽然主题完全不同，但绝对是一本非常非常棒的书。所以丹，非常感谢你。谢谢大家的收听。我们周四会回来，讨论复活节起义。
Bye-bye. Bye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史余韵》。如需收听奖励剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。网址是restishistorypod.com。网址是restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余韵》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和抢先购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。